hello everyone before we get into the
episode today i just wanted to let you
guys know that our podcast
is actually in the nominations for the
15th annual podcast awards we are both
in the games and hobby section
and the people's choice section but in
order to get into the next round
we need you guys to vote for us and we
need you to vote for us today
nominations close july 31st 9pm eastern
standard time
go to podcastawards.com and then go to
the little thing that says
click me to nominate my favorite
podcasts
if it's a thing you'd like to do that's
awesome if not that's also cool
enjoy the show hello everyone welcome to
another episode of play watch listen i'm
alana i'm joined by austin wintry troy
maker and mike bithell all of us work in
video games in some
capacity and i wanted to start the show
today by talking about
the xbox showcase have you seen this
have you heard about this i
did see the emmy nomination
[Laughter]
he said he'd do it and he did
how else are we going to talk about star
wars since mandalorian clean houses
look we will get back to that i promise
because i am interested in what you have
to say about it
uh but i would like to talk about
we have to because presumably that's
what you're calling the youtube video
right we have to start
i would like to i always have a title in
mind
when i start the show out and then
sometimes i'm like i didn't [ __ ] work
out
and then we're just the entire episode
we're
yeah titling this show takes just as
long as making the show i'm like
hey can somebody time stamp me to when
they're actually talking about something
relevant to the topic 55 minutes
these these guys sure do ramble yes
welcome to these this has been five
minutes and i have mentioned xbox but we
haven't actually talked about the
showcase does anyone have what they
would
like to share me
i i'm gonna i'm gonna shout out to the
british developers
it was amazing from like the british
like some of the awesome
stuff coming out of uh what was it was
ever wild which was the rare game
yeah [ __ ] gorgeous what do you think
that game is
i mean i'm guessing third person action
game set in a semi-open world like every
other game right i mean
like i don't i couldn't tell what parts
of that game
i don't know what you're going to do in
that game i think it's going to be more
almost
co-op that i think is going to have
here's the deal i don't know if we talk
i feel like we talked about this i feel
like i'm taking crazy pills
you just had a phone call with austin
again yeah why but that it
i was watching that and i went i feel
like
i was pitched this game
like they they wanted me to be a part of
it and at the end of the day i was like
it just doesn't feel like the right
thing for me it was a small indie studio
and as i'm watching i'm like this looks
really familiar
and i was like this is rare which went
through that pipeline no right now
um it's medium rare it's obviously rare
that troy says no
because yeah true story
i mean it's just
[Laughter]
he's quick this morning austin's been up
since earlier than any of us he's like
i got him brewing uh but no
i i gotta say that hit harder than
expected i i feel i feel blind
because he said yes to mike as well you
know
that's true and the beauty the beauty of
not being mike's first choice on top of
it yeah everything
that's true um god damn it i guess give
me troy baker
[ __ ] um
yes there was a there was a beauty of
everything that i saw ever while i was
one of them that was like look at uh
look at look at microsoft kind of doing
these beautiful little
more stylized indie studio feel
i feel like that has always kind of been
a space which is another one the gunk
that looked really pretty um fantasy
type but also look family friendly like
they
i feel like actually both of the
conferences uh had
more family-friendly stuff than i'm used
to seeing them have which i
like because it's a response to switch
too i think it's like
culturally yeah we saw that happen with
the wii right
there was there was a big over correct
when i mean even
thq was like as we talked about before
you know we comes out and it's like oh
this is how you sell hardwares you make
it marketable to everyone from eight to
eighty
and so let's do stuff more stuff like
that and nobody could
capture that like even disney
interactive couldn't capture that market
it was just wholly left over to the
first one to market
so i think that this is a response to
also some switch stuff i'm like man
people are really yes we have our big
tentpole aaa titles and we're definitely
going to showcase those kicking off with
halo
and then we kind of like show hey we're
also this
where we also deal in art not just
commerce so i thought i thought it was a
pretty i mean that would have to be part
of the calculation with the
just because that psychonauts 2 is part
of it the acquisition of double fine
um like had to have been part of that
play
anyway since they're not able to swansea
man
they're still i'm sorry i just cut you
off completely but it is that i'm gonna
keep going anyway apologies
um the it's the it's it's it's they're
still reeling from the tv conference
that's what all of this feels like a
reaction to to me is do you remember
that
the the awful xbox conference like at
the start of the year yeah that was
like one of the worst we've ever had the
don matric tv conference
it was terrible i feel like i don't i
don't feel like i don't remember that so
they did a comp they they announced the
card it was the xbox one review
they did the xbox one reveal they made
the decision to have the xbox one reveal
be about hardware and services and then
the plan was always to come in
a little bit later and actually reveal
the games what they essentially did was
they launched the games console they did
a games console announce
and they didn't show any games and that
became kind of that
basically you could argue gave a lot of
feel to sony in that
kind of in that moment to come out and
be where the where the guys making games
and there was also the stuff
i mean it was also connected as always
yeah you couldn't
uh share used games like it was just an
atrocious conference and i do feel like
phil spencer has been
trying to recover from that the whole
time but when you say it's about
quantity
i actually don't think that that's
related to that conference i think it's
about quantity because of game pass
so all these studio acquisitions a lot
of which are really good i'm actually
very excited about that uh obsidium game
i think
avowd is the one that i was like oh this
could be
really good is that the is that the
prequel to disavowed
sorry i'll shut up i apologize i guess
uh that that i thought looked
particularly awesome but yeah
when you have all these studios it's
because you want the subscription
service that you have where people can
play any game they want to have as many
games on it as possible and of course it
will be interesting to see
next generation uh what that means for
quality
um these are all i mean but it's
definitely a budget thing there's
definitely a budget
like element like i saw someone tweet
this and it's totally true
if you look at that with like the
developer budget brain
they're definitely making more games at
a lower price point than sony are making
fewer games but at a higher much
that's not me criticizing the games
that's an important distinction though
mike
is that it feels it feels like they're
doing that but are they doing it in
front you said they're making
that are more expensive looking do you
think that they're it's just
production value or is the production
budgets are going do you feel are going
this is all i think they're i think
and this is completely unfounded i think
they're making a choice
um outside of the big temple so
something like halo obviously is is very
much a spend as much as you need kind of
situation
but with all the games like we're
talking about these kind of the smaller
games
the stuff from rare the stuff that
they're bringing in from independent
studios i think there is a definite kind
of intention to kind of spread their
bets
which plays into orlando saying of like
having new content lots and lots of
games
is good for them as a as a subscription
service whereas sony is very much about
kind of
reminded like something like last of us
they're talking about last of us for
like
what two three years before it comes out
it's uh yeah it's a big kind of
ambitious you know genre defining kind
of project
i'm not saying that the microsoft
projects don't look cool they look
really cool but they also look very
practically made and kind of things that
we're going to get to play
in a much shorter space of time and do
you think that spreading their bets
i i feel like do you think that it's a
sustainable
model or mentality to make as many as
possible
in a kind of gristmill way just because
we live in a world like you look at it
that's what they're doing i don't think
there's many games it's like i want to
be i want to be really clear i'm not
saying they look cheap i'm saying they
look
shorter that's what i'm thinking they
probably are going to be definitely
going to be more often
and i mean there are 10 million game
pass subscribers already
uh it's not like they haven't been
making that money also microsoft is the
biggest company
in the world when it comes to their
actual market capital like they have so
much money
um obviously they're trying to repeat
that uh with game pass but also with
xcloud by going to
mobile is like part of what they're
doing with xcloud like they want to get
every market
in the world on this thing because there
is so much untapped money in the games
market uh
with the way that we make games in the
west which is all console focused and
i mean i i feel like that money's coming
sorry please no go ahead
i'm being really rude this no i'm being
terribly rude this up so please go for
it i was just gonna say to what you were
saying mike
which is that if sony are making these
blockbuster titles like your gods of
wars and your last of us
and your horizon uh forbidden wests
you got your uh the last of us and you
got your halos and you got your
uh horizons and writings
but then xbox are making smaller titles
that are like
i'm guessing like a hellblade 2 is going
to be a five hour experience
as someone who is automatically invested
in both of those ecosystems i feel like
i'm winning
i get both of those things it's great
and also and they're making more money
from you which is the interesting aspect
in terms of especially with game pass
because
everything flows through game pass so
even if you i know if you're an
if you're playing an indie game through
game pass the money's coming into
microsoft
and then microsoft have done a deal with
that indie studio and those deals can
take different forms but
the money is always flowing through
microsoft if you're making if you're
selling a console
and then you know that ubisoft ea
activision are going to be making their
games releasing them yes you get a
little cut of every game that's released
but you don't control the entire economy
which is which is part of this is if
they know
with a subscription model they know how
much money is coming in every month it's
a really
predictable understandable number um it
keeps
their cash flow really clear through the
year that's the other aspect of the
game's business is for
aaa they make a lot of their money in
the in q4 not so much money in q1 and q2
you know it's though there's that kind
of that distribution throughout the year
you're basically hitting just a very
consistent very high cash flow
and yeah you've got a very predictable
budget they they will have the number
within microsoft of like
these are the probably and it definitely
is hundreds of millions of dollars we
can spend a year
on this content for this platform
because we know people are there and we
can kind of we can boost that halo is
going to bring an enormous number of
players
but they know that they're going to have
to keep those players subscribing in the
same way as
if if you notice that you've not watched
anything on netflix for two months
you're gonna unsubscribe
right and they're gonna make more money
from you with something like netflix
um because you're not buying individual
products with sony yes you're gonna go
and buy last of us day of release but
you're not gonna buy another game from
sony first party for maybe
a year yeah two years six months right
if you're not interested in ghost of
tsushima and you're a sony fan
and you're you know big on first party
playstation games you bought last of us
you're not gonna buy anything else until
ps5 launch day well that's why i feel
like
the playstation approach is to make
these huge blockbuster titles to get you
to buy their hardware so then you're
going to subscribe to playstation plus
or playstation now potentially i feel
like they need to work on now but
then they make the money off of every
third-party game sale
yeah so in theory they're making all of
that revenue but i do feel like
yeah that that subscription model is
probably something that both sides are
just going to push
further for this generation but related
to subscriptions i read a study that
says that people
generally don't cancel subscription
services
it can be up to nine months since the
last time they've used it before they
will actually realize they have to
cancel and i did that with crunchyroll
i am the same i am like below some price
point
it definitely flies below the radar in a
way that that
i'm not especially proud of uh where
i'll then
i'll then realize like oh crap i've been
paying for
you know hulu for for the last six
months and i've i haven't used so i'll
like
binge i'll i'll do an obscene amount of
binging to kind of catch to make myself
feel like i'm
i'm i'm i'm recouping that in some in
some way the loss
yeah that's why it's such a good system
sorry go ahead
i will also do like we just did an audit
of of subscriptions that were like why
do we have this
like i had like epics and i had epics
for one show that's not even on anymore
so i'm like i don't need this anymore so
i went and we did a mass culling
of all of our superfluous subscriptions
that we have that's one question that i
was curious about is what do you think
the rate of attrition will be
for people with game pass i haven't
honestly i
i i'm this is not a hate thing but my
xbox
is i'm looking at it and is 100
unplugged
but i still have my xbox live account
and that gets charged annually
and so i still pay for it so i
understand that the model of like
get them in there and it's like trying
to i think i said this maybe to you
austin it's like
i've been able to break up with people
easier than it is to cancel some
subscriptions it's like
it's it's almost nigh impossible are you
sure you want to get what if we did this
what if we
what if we gave you three of these three
months for free or what if we allowed
you to do this
and so though i'm sure they'll
incentivize people just just to maintain
retention but my question is still i
know that we've talked about it and i
think mike you're probably the best one
to answer this
spotify is great for our
artists in a certain sense because but i
believe
that there's more people that are
listening to a wider swath of music
than what was being cranked through top
40 radio it's a controversial
statement just worth adding in there uh
uh but
but i don't want to derail you sure go
ahead yeah i would love to hear what you
think
well no it is it is hardly the consensus
amongst
the music community that spotify is good
for the music community
i actually am a because their payout is
so
is so small it's it's good for the
artist in one sense and it's bad for the
artist
what's been super detrimental to kovid
is before you never made your money as
an artist on your record that's i mean
you potentially could if you were doing
like taylor swift numbers or whatever
but the you made your money in three
ways through merchandising touring and
publishing
those three are the places that you're
going to make a living off of that is if
your song gets placed
or if the label goes we're going to buy
your catalog and we're going to buy it
for a lot of money but you're never
going to see another dime for it for the
next 30 years
or you're going to do all of your
merchandising which is how
kiss set that model they trademarked and
the label laughed at them it's like you
can have all of our albums
we want the merchandising and they
trademark kiss they trademark the font
and anything that has the kiss logo or
name on it
trademarked tongues they trade i mean
every they're being jeans
but they get they get all of that and
and primarily i think it was gene
simmons
so it's kind of like george lucas you
can be able to keep the merchandising
rights and then
do you know that story right just as a
tangent within a tangent that
that lucas uh fox gave him the merch
right supposedly
i love that we get a star wars thing in
here you know uh
what happened uh fox what i had heard
was that fox gave him the merch rights
because
basically this movie was behind schedule
and over budget and it was in a genre
that was considered extremely niche the
highest
performing sci-fi up until 1977 was
still
2001 which was almost a decade earlier
and had made like 15 million dollars and
this was
you know a couple years after jaws blew
open the notion of the summer
blockbuster and you know
was making like hundreds of millions of
dollars and so star wars was not
considered a viable candidate for that
kind of thing
at all and um and so
and fox didn't believe in it because it
was like seemingly accursed production
you know they'd had sandstorms to store
their set and
for tatooine and all this kind of stuff
so lucas said can i retain the
merchandise right so that i can
basically manufacture stuff myself and
go to comic-con type
you know predecessors to those sorts of
things for trade shows and
uh just a hawk merchandise hawk the
merchandise in order to um
drum up some grassroots interest in the
movie and they were basically like
well this is a dead horse like this
thing is dead on arrival anyway
so we're not giving away anything of
value um
so they were like sure go ahead you know
if your little one-man army is going to
go help sell our movie then have at it
and of course
they gave away what could yeah like god
knows what the toy industry
like star wars changed actually has
literally changed the whole industry
changed our approach to even the
comments right
i got it i got it i got to uh because
you're i wonder if they're
gonna be mike bithell right now yeah i'm
gonna do my version
star wars action figures change the toy
industry that's my setup talk amongst
yourself for 30 seconds because
what oh he's he's he does this what i
was going to say was
it's it's beneficial for the artists in
the sense that there's artists that i
never would have heard of and i've been
able to enjoy the music and i became a
fan which could potentially
be more financially beneficial for the
artist
but and it's been detrimental to the
industry as well like the record
industry is like [ __ ] i don't know how
to make money on this
so what they ended up doing come yeah
austin that's so cool
i want to let you know that he is also
in a loving relationship too by the way
like he's he ticks all the boxes awesome
this is every single original from 1977.
oh my god
so if if [ __ ] goes south he can always
sell that if this music thing doesn't
work out
you can always just go that is so cool
i didn't i don't even think i knew you
had that dude where was that i i may not
have a magic bookcase but i do have a
complete
uh star wars toy collection holy [ __ ]
i did not know you had the original
where is that we're pulling out our 80s
toys
nice what the hell are the original 80s
tron toys i mean i don't have star wars
toys but
it's a hot toys i wonder if bruce box
lightner kind of walked onto that set
thinking he was hot [ __ ] and had no idea
who jeff bridges was he was like you're
the kid with the
red shoes or whatever the computer wore
tennis shoes and he's like i'm bruce
[ __ ] box lightner and i'm tron
it's like every everybody's gonna
remember just after this
gonna do scarecrow mrs king and then go
away for a long time
and pray for his sequel um he has the
best line in the entire movie which is
we made it
this far
[Laughter]
that's a true story right there um
but only only by taught by jeff bridges
because jeff bridges goes like finish
it finish the game no he just screams
for no reason oh it's such i love tron
so much and you're honest
i'm asking a question there's okay yes
sorry go ahead go ahead
yep that one's on me do you feel yes
they can now say
hey quarters quarters are kind of like
irrelevant because we're going to be
making money
you know on on the constant and now we
can be able to predictably
have this model that says we're going to
have three percent attrition
and that where you have this many users
and where growth rate is this so we can
say
we're going to have x many millions of
dollars to be able to spend on games
and while yes the halos are going to get
the majority of that
do you feel that that is going to be
beneficial to
the indie dev or do you think that the
only way it becomes beneficial is if
microsoft goes it will only bid if you
if you come under our shingle and do
like what double fine did
so that microsoft ends up becoming this
aggregator of developers
as opposed to just being a publisher we
know it already has helped some indies
but like double fine
no no no no like um like tiny builds
like there are people who
whose games have only gotten audiences
since they were on game pass and have
seen a correlation with sales increase
by up to 10
times since they were on game pass
because of the amount of new eyes that
are on those games so
there's a few answers to gameplay one is
what exactly alana's talking about which
is
which is yes having your game in front
of more people it does help
and and i think rather than something
like spotify where
it's all of music ever you know because
this is more limited
kind of platform your game is being put
in front of people more because it's
being served on that storefront
spotify doesn't have a front page where
they show you every song that's been
released that day or if they do
no one ever goes there you go and listen
to what you want they do to a degree but
i think it's like steam
where the the amount on the front page
versus the amount
after that is uh ten thousand to one
yeah
so right now like a company yeah like a
like like tiny build with their stuff
that they've talked about or or
like you know definitely seen the same
thing happen with like thomas was alone
when that's been in
various ones of these and and um you
know i think i mentioned this last week
but rocket league
was the same thing rocket league has a
ps plus title uh on launch
and then just blew up and look at it now
go free to
actually it's interesting seeing with
full guys uh they seem to be kind of
trying to mimic the same approach right
full guys is launching
either in or it launched like a week ago
but now it's in august
8th i believe forever it's like very
soon
it's very quick like it's either
launching it or within a month
and and that's i think that's exactly
doing the luckily thing but there's the
other thing that people don't really
talk about as much
and i guess it's less glamorous or
interesting but it's important
we're not we're not going into things
like game pass out of charity
we're being paid um sure people
think i think people think it's like
spotify where it's like oh you get
10 cents for everyone who downloads your
game that's not how it works it's a buy
out usually with these things i'm
speaking very generally i'm not sure
okay
that changes my perspective so i'm not
under i'm not gonna talk about any
company i may or may not have ndas with
but speaking generally about these kind
of schemes and approaches i feel like we
need a
hidden lawyer representative sometimes
can you say that
i can't say that i have my lawyer on
like autism yeah are like
shots callers somebody just kind of
comes into screens like
upon further review there's gonna be a
trans-dimensional one that's
going back through all our windows like
leans in whispers to mike then leans
into my window whispers to me
we need an ai sorry we have him on
retainers
exactly but it's like there's serious
money involved in a lot of these deals
and
i think like you know some of them have
been publicized some of them haven't
we've certainly
done very well from uh you know when
you've seen our games kind of launch in
an exclusive space or come to an
exclusive space
after launch um of course money's
involved of course they pay us like then
there's
and the kinds of money that's available
is actually like
covering budgets or covering a couple of
budgets you know and putting money in
the developers pocket to
go and make more games um and that
varies it's like any
marketplace it depends on like how
valuable your thing is seen as how much
they think it's going to bring people to
the platform
um how popular your games have been
historically and all of these data
points and various things but
yeah there is effectively there's two
ways a platform will pay you they'll pay
you with literal cash
or um there's the the more vague side of
it which is marketing support so
i don't think again people realize that
like when you see a game on like your
favorite
um store on like a console's uh online
store on
through the through the console itself
or via shop fronts the
slots are not like that's not based on
necessarily meritocracy it's based on
like who's gotten a good marketing deal
or a marketing support deal with one of
these platform holders
so you cut those kind of deals so
there's lots of benefits i can
i can be in a situation you could you
end up with weird things and again this
is
super vague and this is using
theoretical conversations but like
there are like you could theoretically
go well i want my game to launch
i know it's not i you know i know i'm
not going to make much
money on platform x but they're willing
to support me with marketing say
so my game can be perceived on that
platform as a big deal and then that
will knock on to more money being made
on other platforms
you've got this kind of you could
actually you can almost have a platform
i've never done this but
it's almost like the producers you could
actually intentionally go
we're going to develop a port for this
platform
we know it won't sell on that platform
but we know we can get marketing support
which will then
impact all these other platforms there's
loads of ways as a developer that you
can kind of
do this and to be clear kind of getting
paid in exposure
i mean basically but at this scale
you know and with these actually the
exposure does have value and that's an
interesting kind of
bouncing but no it's not i think people
look at this a lot and they go well this
is like spotify this is like
if i download thomas was alone in ps
plus or game pass
i'm giving mike gets five cents or
whatever that's not how
usually um with these kind of platforms
it will be like a buyout it'll be like
they came to me
and said here's a big bag of money can
we have your game on our platform for x
months
interesting and then it's a choice of
like do you want to take the bag of
money or not
um and there's lots of and then that
becomes a thing of like well if we're
doing that does that
does that piss off a gamer who's bought
it last week or does this
or does that mean we can't release it on
this other platform so there's always
these kind of choices being made but
yeah
it's not if you see a game being given
prominence an event
and being launched exclusively in like a
console's platform
that company's probably been paid for
their work quite substantially and
you shouldn't feel bad for them like
that's a good thing not not feeling bad
i guess i just i want to look at it
globally and go
look there's never going to be a
solution that is like this benefits the
publisher and the developer and the
consumer
it's it's never going to be that fair
and equitable it's always going to be
like
this is going to be something that
ultimately is a better deal for the
consumer
but in the long game we're going to be
able to do this i understand there's
this balance it's never
exactly how is that how did you not just
because you were
you you said what i was going to reply
with which i feel like
contradicts your your point to me the
thing that
that is good for the consumer that's
actually good for the consumer is the
one that will also
finance the developers to be able to
make more games
yes in the future so assuming a zero-sum
game you're assuming that the
uh that we can't yeah you can have um
you can be playing it's like it's game
theory if we all have different goals
and objectives
my goal and objective as a developer is
to have a steady cash flow so my team
stays employed
oh wow troy troy's about to drop some
[ __ ] truth bombs
um um i you know my goal is like steady
cash flow so my team
is employed right and that we get to
keep making games
your goal as a consumer is to get the
most for as little cost and the best
service
fair enough and the the platform's goal
is to
uh keep their audience happy um
and to you know not go over budget with
what they're
paying for all three of us can benefit
it can be a perfect situation where all
three of us have achieved our goal in
that transaction it doesn't
have to always be i think sometimes
these conversations get framed as kind
of a combative kind of
consumer versus corporations kind of
conversation and
usually you can you when it works well
and you're trying to be a good person a
good business owner you can
work out a way that everyone benefits
and it's it's good for
everyone that's not always the case i
definitely don't want to kind of
imply that that's always the way it
works out so for you do you feel that
game pass
is that fair and equitable
it's again like if you if you read marks
like communism on paper
makes a whole lot of sense it's it is
we haven't got time to roll into marx
i'm just gonna we're gonna we're gonna
do the the we're gonna we're gonna do
the
the the debate on the on marxism at some
point but like the um
i think i mean i would rather everyone
paid me sixty dollars for my indie game
and it sold
five five million units or six years but
would you do that
but would you do that though i could
sell my game at 60 dollars and sell five
million units i'd do it yeah
okay let's say you could do that or it's
like hey if you do this
and you this is this is social economy
which is great
you can either make 60 a game or you can
make
and by the way i understand you're not
making 60 a game
but i'm just using that as a figure
right so you can either make 60
on the game or you can make 40
on that game and what that means is that
that the the
the twenty dollars that you would have
made would have gone into a pool that
will allow other developers to also be
able to make their game are you willing
to do that
what would your channel oh yeah i mean
that's well that's that's working with a
publisher right you can you can you can
say that
like every time you work with a
publisher that's the theory like if you
i mean you could you could make an
argument that like publishers are in
themselves kind of a
redistribution system because
essentially publishers go into deals
they'll they'll sign up 10 games
and they assume one of those games is a
mega hit two of those games may
break even and the rest lose the money
and as long as that balance is out
and all of the development teams who
made those games got paid
and got to kind of live while they made
the game
um so so yeah i mean that's that's
something that's just a part of any
entertainment by virtue of making a
successful game with any publisher you
are in theory just continuing to help
the industry
you're funding the rest of their rest of
their games
if for example you you worked with a
publisher and you had a licensed game
that had a
big brand and therefore you knew you
were going to make reasonable money
um yes that would run that publisher in
doing other more interesting
kind of games with other people as well
so you operate under that assumption
like you you guys like look we all get
what we're actually doing
everyone's gonna make their money i'm an
outlier i'm an outlier because i'm i'm
definitely the kind of guy who's like
i don't need to make all the money i can
just make enough
and that's that's not necessarily how
every company operates in the world for
sure
but you also have like a smaller you're
a smaller shop i'm happy to
exactly like i can afford to be nice
with that i can afford to say
we don't need to be millionaires we can
just
keep going and they i i value uh
stability and
long-term kind of ability i mean i feel
like
you say this all the time your approach
is make sure that your team gets paid
and then make games that you like and
i'm like that seems great it seems like
a great way to
run it yeah you're not trying to be a
millionaire support people and make
games you like
but there are definitely also the long
play who would be like if you're not
maximizing you should be taking bigger
risks and you should be making
you know crazy bets and therefore your
opportunity is to
that you'll do something that blows up
and becomes fortnite
i'm less risky i'm more risk-averse i
play things a bit more stunningly it's
you know different people do differently
there's one thing with i mean i think
there are like potential
long-term negative effects of game pass
that it's going to be really interesting
to see what happens but one thing that
i know bothers a lot of people is that
you don't own any of those games of
course you don't own any game you buy
digitally
but you are really just renting them and
then returning them to the blockbuster
after a month or two
um and i think we may have spoken about
this on the show before but
uh i believe it's the case that you
don't even technically own games you buy
physically you just own a physical
version of that license so
really it's just a license you never own
a video game kind of no matter what
um but it is it it does suck like i i
had this with uh abzu that i i
downloaded it on game pass i played half
of it
and then it was gone by the time i went
to finish it so i bought the game but my
approach to that was like well
i'm super happy to support absolutely so
but then
like the same model yeah the same model
applies like
even you're financing you're financing
my star wars collectible
advice if you if you can remember
like on a vhs that fbi warning that
would come up
and say you know you are not allowed to
distribute this or show this in any way
um even if you bought that movie
you don't own that movie you can't go do
a screening of it you can't reproduce it
in any way you can't do anything with it
you simply are you have a copy of that
movie that does not make the movie yours
in the same way that if i buy a game i
don't own that game
that game is still the property of sony
or microsoft or whomever
i'm simply allowed to access that
material
for the pure purpose of playing that
game
the fact that no what do you mean
no no i can't do anything with that like
i was going gonna bring up something
else go ahead go ahead
but even like streaming that game where
i'm creating content and then also
being able to make money off of that
is the industry going technically you
shouldn't be able to do that but we
understand that that's better for the
industry so we're going to allow i feel
like someone's going to crack down
at some point i mean nintendo kind of
did but yes the fact that you are
allowed to make content out of video
games that you can then monetize
is crazy you can't do that with music
you can't do that with film
but you can do it with games and that to
me is what sets the industry apart of
going
we understand what's for the greater
good and what's been for the greater
good
is that there are by and large people
that will never pick one of these up
but they will like how many
how many views you have like a hundred
million views
on or like jacksepticeye has 26 million
subscribers up to 26 million subscribers
or pewdiepie
has over 50 million subscribers
markiplier there are people that don't
own a console
don't own a game for sure that are
viewing that material and they're like i
didn't play but i did watch it and
that's how they're interacting with it
is that good for the industry
or is that potentially detrimental
because there's no consumer there
over 30 development studios about this
particular thing
about how streaming or let's plays
affect the industry
um and the general consensus for most of
them is that it is a positive
but there are certain games that it does
not help
um like that dragon cancer is an example
the one i was going to bring up that's
the studio where they were like
this didn't help us at all this kind of
screwed us um but i don't know that i
agree with their assessment it felt like
they were
they made a game that was the definition
of
niche um yeah and and probably way more
people
became aware of it and were affected by
it than
like that was a game that to me i backed
it on kickstarter
and when i played through it i was a
complete emotional wreck
and the thing that really uplifted me
while the credits rolled
was seeing just how many of my friends
and colleagues in the industry were
listed in the kickstarter special thanks
and i realized this was one where the
whole community
not the whole community but a huge swath
of developers
people at publishers they gave money
because they said we
think this game needs to join our ranks
of
games that are available which that's
watching it
rather than buying it and that's giving
them funding for that
yeah and i think that the game was so
is so emotionally intense in the same
way that
a movie about anything to do with
that kind of level of subject matter is
never going to compete with
mcu or transformers because
because it's just it's it's you can put
the biggest stars on the planet
in a movie like that and most people are
just not gonna
they're not gonna want to go there
emotionally and so i've i've i believed
in those people i literally gave them
hundreds of dollars as part of their
kickstarter campaign
i was really i'll never ever forget
playing that game
but i thought it felt
uh i don't know i don't know the best
way to put it but it
it it it felt like a strange kind of
almost like whining
to blame uh the
streamer community for their lack of
commercial success when they made a game
where commercial success was stacked
against it so severely from the
beginning and it was one of those and i
say that with all respect for them
and not never mind the fact that what
they went through is real and i will
hopefully would never relate to that and
so it's like i i i mean i choose my
words
cautiously i wish them only the best and
i wish it had been a commercial success
but
that's where i'm like yeah i i think
it's overall
i think the cases where it could
actually be demonstrated to have hurt
them are
next to none yeah i think you're
probably right because that you're right
that game is so
specifically niche and in fact there's a
lot of the people who maybe made content
about it wouldn't have even necessarily
played it unless they were making
content about it because it is so small
um but there is another side to the
uh like how does the the streaming
let's play community affect video games
and a big one is for twitch specifically
um it seems like and again this is just
from i interviewed a bunch of studios
about it
uh services games of service games do
better
uh on a platform like twitch which is
because
other players are creating the content
rather than the devs having to
necessarily create the content obviously
itself to emerging content yeah it is
ever evolving you can make one map
like pubg was originally and
continuously
get hours and hours and hours of content
out of that on a streaming service
because
again other players are the ones who are
making the content change every time and
i mean sure it's rng there are different
drops but
it is they are the ones who are making
it entertaining not
what the devs have actually necessarily
put in themselves they made the tools
so that the definition of transformative
right pretty much yeah
transformative nice
so i guess the the thing with that is uh
with twitch games taking off that again
are generally things that have more
player interactivity
could make a lot of devs want to play or
want to create more games like that
because they see that as a marketing
opportunity which obviously isn't going
to work if too many of them are doing it
does also seem to tie in with the way
that microsoft is making games right now
though
and i'm curious to see if that stacks up
which is like i never expected rare to
make a game like sea of thieves
uh there were rumors that fable um which
obviously playground i'm making
was going to be an mmo and i was like
garbage but
microsoft maybe could do that they're
absolutely not thank god i'm so happy
that that's not gonna be an mmo
uh but they are making games of service
games and i think that that is for the
same reason that games are serviced with
that renewable content that is ongoing
that you will play forever because it is
constantly changing by virtue of other
players
is a good thing to subscribe to it is it
makes sense with game pass for you to
make games and service games which again
makes me very happy that
we have multiple big companies in this
industry because i don't want to lose
massive blockbuster single-player titles
like xbox had last generation like your
bioshock
like your mass effect that now we have
from sony i feel like more strongly
i feel like nintendo is still making
some of those titles too like obviously
breath of the wild is going to be one of
my favorite games of the entire
generation
so i'm just glad that we have multiple
companies still existing and still being
profitable because otherwise i feel like
if it were just driven by business we
probably would see everything going the
direction of games of service
subscription and i don't want that
well i think it is driven by netflix
netflix is absolutely dominated
and we don't want that we don't want
that kind of one
at least netflix is still making
different stuff though right
so like they'll publish the irishman and
then
they'll publish stranger things like
they're still we're still getting very
different pieces of content from netflix
they just want whatever you'll watch
whereas i feel like the video game
industry has the potential to be a
little bit more homogeneous than that
um i feel like it cut you off there
austin oh my
god i'm apologizing for him yeah
now you said it you know you said
something like i'm glad it's not 100
driven by
business which might somehow yield
everybody ending up at games for service
but that's where i feel like it's
actually because it's driven by business
that people realize that there are
gamers that don't want that
and and would be willing to pay for a
god of war a last of us
a bioshock no i do think the industry is
100 driven by business i will
say that and i i still do think those
single-player titles when
uh when it comes down to it even with
playstation exist because they want you
to buy their hardware because they want
you to get in their ecosystem
like obviously the teams making those
games like i seem to have a lot of
creative freedom from what i can tell
where playstation is concerned
um like i i tweeted about this the other
day but the fact that
sucker punch made ghosts tsushima and
gorilla makes horizon zero dawn and
those are games that look
nothing like anything those studios have
ever made before and they're so creative
and so cool that that's a risk to make
those new ips and have them be that
different from what the studio has
proven they can do is awesome and very
glad that stuff exists but
playstation themselves are still green
lighting that because i like this might
sell playstations
we want you to buy playstations again
well crucially as well
the everything you're describing is also
mark like like
from a business point of view like yes
games are a business and ultimately like
we have we have to make people money in
order to be allowed to keep making them
and i'm sure the same issue of worldwide
studios
but well they don't call that anymore
are they they're now playstation studios
right
it's not like worldwide right did they
drop the worldwide i don't know
no it's playstation it's playstation
studios now it was worldwide now it's
anyway
but like it also though what you're
describing is in itself marketing
like the idea of sony has been very
aggressive over
literally like a couple of generations
of console now about
going artistic going kind of we make a
we make a classy kind of game we make
something innovative
there are games that they've put out
like that don't make much money but that
have had sequels and stuff because
they're weird or quirky or interesting
or different or cool
and i think that's part of that is in
itself marketing like
where is knack free allowing
allowing your creative teams to be
creative is also a good business
strategy
if your business strategy is for people
to think of playstation as the place
where there is that kind of innovation
and that kind of originality
i mean for what it's worth it all ties
back in my my career would not exist if
what you
just said were not true you you were
going to work on deck
exactly no that's true i mean journey is
is playstation doing that and i've
actually that's like a very good point
that i've actually never thought about
mike is that
there is also because i feel like i do
really think about this stuff in a way
that's like very much
this company needs to make this much
money to continue to keep making money
and i mean the industry functions that
way in a lot of ways but there is
absolute absolutely value to playstation
in
appearing as the platform for you to get
creative single-player emotional
experiences where i feel like xbox is
more focused on
multiplayer with your friends i agree
with that i mean when i get meta you
could even say playstation has
excellently targeted a specific group of
people throughout their lives
i think there's
young person now there's a lot of games
about dads
you know the playstation 36 and just
been
when you see simon pegg have grandkids
prepare for every playstation game to
have a grandkid plot in it because it's
genuinely like they're it's the space
generation they're following
through to some extent while also
obviously trying to bring in other
people into the folder
i mean i think the data is just that the
the people
riding those games want to focus on that
material rather than an executive
decision from playstation feature more
dads
so it's it's like when they did insomnia
no i don't know i think they're green
lighting i think they're making choices
i do
i think there's i think there's possible
decision making going on yeah sorry go
ahead
when christopher nolan did insomnia he
was inspired to do that movie because it
was when his child was first born and he
wasn't sleeping at all he was like this
would be terrible to have insomnia so he
he wrote and and did insomnia so i agree
that it's kind of like
the people that are making the games now
are doing so based upon like
neil wrote the last of us when he had
his first
child so i mean it's like what would i
do if somebody tried to take this child
away from me right
um but i i think that also sony is kind
of the mac
and microsoft is kind of the pc you know
it's sony what they did was microsoft is
the microsoft
microsoft is the microsoft
but like sony created the culture like
you said there's so many fanboys there's
not really
microsoft fanboys you know what i mean
disagree oh
uh i would say it depends on the
generation i think that the three-state
syria had more
right now yeah i mean playstation has
sold more units so we know we're not
talking about user base i'm talking
about
culture fandom i promise you
as someone who has covered goes to
sushima and the last of us on my youtube
channel
that xbox boys are in here like [ __ ] you
play sea of thieves like i
promise you those people very strongly
exist
i don't think i'm not saying they don't
exist i'm just saying by and large
sony has seemed to cultivate a commute
or cultivate a culture
rather than a fan or rather than a user
base i think there's a strong
moment where you're realizing how much
the time code for this point of the
podcast is gonna be commented
[Music]
there are more playstation fans right
now from my perception um and i think
that that is probably
based on you know sales is in theory
a viable perception um but i
i do definitely think that there are
hardcore xbox fans who are never going
to falter
not saying that there's not i'm not
saying that there's not what i'm saying
is that sony has made a philosophical
choice as a company to try to cultivate
a culture
more than microsoft has so you're saying
that microsoft was adopted by certain
types of people
sony almost
microsoft in a different way than sony
was sony's whole thing was powered to
the player
they they've just the philosophy of sony
is different than
here's our hardware here's our software
and and this is the ex
these are the things that you want and
they they were more like
creating a culture i i just by and large
see that
like you even said mike is like there's
this generation of people like i just
kind of always played playstation i have
a ps1 ps2 ps3 ps4 ps5 that's what that's
how i went and even like the handheld
version of that too is like
they use their hardware to create a
culture more than what microsoft did i'm
not saying
one's better i think if you look i think
if you looked like 10 years younger i
think you're right for our generation
potentially like i think there is
like i think there are because you
because essentially what the way the
playstation
uh one was like initially marketed was
as a clubbing it was
it was all about the club scene it was
all about uh you know you come back from
the party and that's so weird
it was all over my team back to the
original playstation
yeah so the original playstation that
was it was all tied into club culture
no way a lot of the stuff that a lot of
the games look at the games of the era
they were made for people who were high
like essentially like it was tied to
that culture so weird i'm not saying
true story anyway in condones
but then you see xbox come along
you need a name for the lawyer
whispering in your ears yeah
[Music]
like 10 years later 15 years later and
you can see that they were keyed into
um well actually with microsoft they've
specifically keyed into like
sport energy drinks and um and
uh extreme sports i was gonna say halo
is a game about a guy running around in
a
like in an extreme like a motor sports
costume
[Applause]
i'm so sorry what does it look like i've
got this thing from motocross you're
absolutely right it really does look
like a motocross
i think mike you're so the oddworld game
was all about um
they lent into that it's not slurm is it
that's that's futurama
the drink they all drink in oddworld was
all tied to like energy growing graphics
the fact that it's lime green
to make you think of that kind of that
era that specific kind of early 2000s
okay well it's what i'm saying is they
both did the same thing
and then and then they kind of grew
culturally and i think what what troy's
saying there's validity to it that like
for our generation we were teenagers
when playstation was the
the cool up-and-comer i think there's a
generation behind us for whom xbox had
the same role where playstation was the
kind of
slightly dusty and more traditional
console and xbox was
what you played because that was the
thing that was being endorsed by your
favorite sports
guy i think you know as validation for
that
behind you sorry austin go ahead well
just one quick anecdote that supports
that is say that
it makes me feel sad um i think i am
the uh the um when i was growing up and
i was
you know massive gamer my entire
childhood i was definitely as someone
growing up
in the 80s and 90s being a gamer was
like the cliche
you're in your parents basement kind of
thing and i remember the first time
that the people i associated with like
the bro dude bullies that
hated people like me for being gamers
was people playing
halo on xbox and frat houses in college
is because that was a game that managed
to appeal to a different
now i'm not i'm not equivocating i'm not
equating those
and saying that like the initial
adopters of xbox were the [ __ ]
of the world it was like they managed to
well they made it
disarmed fascinating and i would love to
like
you just triggered i have this thing in
my brain where i'm like write a feature
about that
because what you're almost suggesting is
that uh
that original xbox and halo being
marketed as
frat bro cool motocross energy drink
paved the way for people who are not
seen as nerds to get more involved in
video games yeah i think that's exactly
it's the same thing as when you tie
playstation to the club scene in the 90s
same objective you know it's exactly the
same thing as they
nintendo have always been the company
that they make games that are
entertaining and
if you think they're silly that's that's
on you there's enough people who like
nintendo and they've they've stuck to
that messaging
like from day one but it does have the
side effect that austin's talking about
like nintendo was seen as a as a kids
console so there was always
the always the opportunity to sell games
consoles to teenagers and that's where
playstation come in
and that's where microsoft come in with
with the xbox with the original xbox
same thing
same same strategy and i can add um team
culture is
all of them again it's very personally
anecdotal but um
but to that notion of what troy was
getting at of
the difference in the types of culture
sort of branding or positioning or how
however you want to frame that
back in the in the day when when we were
approached
um genova chen and nick clark kelly
santiago and not
and i and that very initial embryonic
team that became
that game company for launching flow in
2006
my memory of how that conversation went
down or what i overheard basically
was that sony realized you know with the
ps2 they already had you know god of war
they i assume the ps3 was was just
around the corner to launch and i'm
assuming that
uncharted was already in production um i
can't remember when it
when uncharted one launched but but
2007.
that was okay yeah so it had to have
been yeah so so point is they knew
they were already reputed and obviously
with the relationship with kojima and
things like that like they already had
the big single player blockbuster
branding thoroughly associated and the
thing that they were going for
with the playstation network which was
their big novel move was
we can approach smaller developers to
make smaller games where it doesn't even
matter if they turn a profit because
first off their their overall cost is so
small
that it's not even a huge loss for us
but but they they draw people in and
they show that we are
this wide spectrum platform from and we
can incubate
weird new talent because i remember they
they they signed us and they signed
jonathan uh mack he john mack made um
uh everyday shooter uh around that same
time and it was like these
very unusual weird games that were like
indie but also they were exclusives to
playstation
and it seemed very much at the time like
they were that was the whole point was
to say
come come for the uncharted stay for the
all the interesting weirdos kind of the
gameplay strategy as well in a certain
way like everyone's still trying to do
this like i was also gonna say
anecdotally like i was
eight when the original xbox came out
and again
very anecdotal very personal but i i
remember my
i'm sorry the way that i looked at them
was uh
playstation was the japanese console
xbox was the american console and i feel
like that's how i saw it in my head was
that
i had because i always had both uh
playstation was the one that
uh i went to for japanese games for
final fantasy for a big rpg and then
xbox was the one that i was playing
brute force on like it was just oh my
god
do you know what's really weird i
thought brute force as you said like
genuinely i thought so you guys were the
ones that started pressing record at the
same time then last week
because we had this point in time yes
and my sister as well
yeah oh my god she stopped playing video
games and i didn't i just kept going but
we grew up playing n64 together and then
we got an xbox in the last game we
finished on co-op before she stopped
playing games with brute force so i
always just tie that with that console
here's a question i used to play halo
and brute force on my little sister
am i remembering this correctly that
microsoft like xbox was the first to go
online before playstation i think is
that is that an accurate statement
i thought xbox live launched before
playstation network but i know xbox live
it did charged before because you had
yeah you had socom
came out i can't remember when i think
socom came out after live though but it
was i thought
halo was one of the first like halo was
kind of like hey you guys can go online
and play this together
like the ability to do that halo was
almost the launch title for gold if i
remember correctly so
yeah that sounds great yes yes halo 2.
um
so that goes on the other one that goes
to your point alana
yeah see that's exactly what i'm talking
about mike that that was the culture
that microsoft was was
building which is one who's like go to
your dudes house and we're gonna play
xbox like it became like the brand name
for playing video games was playing xbox
that was the culture
but that's not what sony's working out
the pc land scene
so we were all like land gamers we all
took our xbox and you plugged it in the
same way
and yeah very cool was 2006. that was
way after four years yeah as i as i
recall the ps3 was the first one to be
natively uh wi-fi enabled which
which uh because as i recall that was
part of the strategy
i could be completely wrong here but if
i remember correctly in those days
actually
because how quickly we forget because
xbox was a plug-in wasn't it the modem
was a plug-in
yeah the 360 the 360 came out
considerably ahead of the ps3 and they
were they were
they were um they it looked like ps3 was
gonna have a pretty serious uphill
battle and what
sony did their their kind of coup move
was by making the ps3
naturally wi-fi as the default state
you remove one barrier to to entry
right there and then on top of that the
playstation network
was you could download games from there
and i don't believe that the
uh like they're like their whole catalog
was quickly becoming available online
um and uh that i think was also
novel if i remember correctly because
you could do that on 360. you could like
you had xbox live arcade and stuff on
360.
but yeah but it was only a live arcade
games
as i recall um yeah you might be right
yeah i think ps3 you might be right ps3
might have done their like
first party big box games downloadable
for the first
and exclusive and and downloadable
exclusives i guess that was the answer
to the live arcade i just remember
i just remember because i'll never
forget my
my i guess it was my second gdc was when
flo at the main big award show won
downloadable game of the year
yeah uh and it was like holy [ __ ] you
know because like bioshock
and portal were winning all the other
awards that night and god of war three
um and uh and so it was you know and
assassin's creed it was quite a year
yeah and um and uh but that
but that notion of like being a
downloadable
title uh was definitely kind of like the
kids pool or the kids table
uh right the wedding reception i feel
like that's now been replaced with
indie game of the year which still kind
of doesn't mean anything
well i never i i don't feel like the
smaller ones yeah i remember mike
bringing up
and some prior uh episode here of
like india's more of a marketing term
than uh that said it in a very sassy way
i recall it
yeah business well it's so true though
because everybody
my my little joke with journey was that
it's and it's still true to this day
uh journey is my rorschach test for
determining someone's
self-identification with indie versus
aaa because i asked them is journey
what which is it to you and basically
anyone who's coming from having worked
on like
uncharted or you know god of war
they instantly peg journey as indie but
if you
are mike bithell yeah exactly if you're
if you're
like those are the two groups people
who've worked on youtube this one or
it was always journey was always the
other camp that you're in because
for the indies yeah it's it was owned
and financed and and exclusively until
very recently published by
sony i remember even genova after flow
and flower you know that game company
had built up quite a lot of
uh street cred as an indie developer
despite this kind of
slight cognitive dissonance and we went
to go record orchestra
for journey and i remember genova going
i wonder if this is going to hurt our
indie street cred because like
you're selling out to the man if you can
afford an orchestra
and uh it was like you know that seems
ridiculous and
goddamn if i didn't see a few forum
posts of people being like
i liked tgc back when they were more
indie and made games like flower and it
was like oh my god
i remember kirk hemet from metallica
saying that
saying the same thing about the exact
same thing
um kirk kevin rolling stone is like you
know the black alvin just come out and
they're like how do you feel when
fans die hard metallica fans respond to
you and say that you're a sellout he
goes they're right
we sold out wembley we sold out
he was like we do sell those like we're
metallica i
respect metallica so much for that point
because they did start up in the same
way they were this gritty speed metal
thrash band
that were able to understand where the
industry was going and grow with it and
that's what i feel like tjc
tjc that game company is like was like
if we want uh it's the same thing that
made neil druckmann go we should make
this thing
a a tv show or or a feature or whatever
is because at the bottom at the end of
the day like i said there's some people
that are just never going to pick this
up and there are people i'm pointing to
a controller
and there are people that are they
believe in the story enough to go
i i care to get this story to the masses
and if that means that i go
this route and i and i i put my you know
my shop under the shingle of microsoft
and become part of mike or playstation
studios
or if i um let a streamer you know
be the one that primarily is
broadcasting my game up to people so
that people
see this story i feel ultimately that is
best
for the industry that is best for games
and yes it means that some people don't
get to
excel and succeed as much as the others
you don't get to rise to that ceiling
but if that's the only goal that is a
short-sighted
doom to fail goal if the only thing is
that xyz company succeeds
that is not a sustainable model for
anything you know what i mean
you have to be able to support
agriculture in order to support a farm
i think sony i i i reference them so
much only because i've got so much
experience working with them but i i
have
only positive experiences working with
them is the thing i mean i have very
positive experience working with
microsoft also
in activision and ubisoft and i've been
very lucky but but sony in particular
nintendo interesting yeah
for this week um yeah i um
but i one thing the one particular way
that it manifested to your point troy
and just into
and even when we were talking a minute
ago about streamers and their their
openness to
to that whole world um the thing that
i've seen it
in my experience a lot is all the number
of uh concert opportunities that came up
uh
as a result of journey and orchestras
around the world saying
can we perform this yeah and every time
i went back to sony to kind of work out
the official paperwork
they they were always like tripping all
over themselves to help make it happen
even so far as and it's not like that's
a money maker for them
uh it's it's just like hey especially
the
exciting ones were when like um like the
pacific symphony as an example
um in um southern california kind of
orange county area
they did a concert of of all classical
music
except they also included journey and so
it was like
there's this there's this idea that
there's
two or three thousand people in the
audience that did not go to this for
video game music
and probably a large contingent of which
would have the knee-jerk assumption that
video game music
is 80s chiptunes that doesn't need to be
taken seriously
yeah it's it was an amazing experience
and and it's amazing
being cynical go ahead
it's not money maker it really is
because that's how you convince the
world that your culture
rather than a product that is the
argument i'm making though that's
i don't think there's a cynicism in that
i'm saying sony is savvy to the idea
that not every transaction is monetary
today
that the idea that people in the
audience journey live is probably the
quintessential example of this where
they gave us carte blanc to basically go
and make a whole concert out of doing
journey
as a show start to finish on stage where
people play the game
and i conduct and we do the music live
and interactive as part of it and
and we sell a journey show and and
sony not only did they not get in our
way they actually got the
the company that was in charge of
porting to ps4 to make us a special ps4
build
that has all the music removed since
there's no ui for doing that in the game
so that we can conduct and do the show
but all the sound effects are intact in
the
in the shouts and the and we had to
specially
whitelist uh the game in order to be
able to play online
through the normal playstation network
as well since we're on we're technically
playing from a dev kit
um and they they went they went out of
their way to see all this happen and
it's not like
it's you know the ticket sales are being
run through
sony's office or something they're like
okay now go do it and basically
allowing us to be messengers for sony on
on their behalf and and it's been
amazing like incredible experience it
reminds me that
we used to do concerts and have
audiences and stuff and the time before
and the long
and i actually i'm sure microsoft has
done plenty of culture stuff but i know
that a thing that they've done really
strongly that is
is really persistent is gears inc which
i think is super interesting
um gears inc is basically uh at
various gears of war events globally
um including when they have their
tournaments or competitions
uh they will hire these specific tattoo
artists who have tattooed a lot of
people with gears of war related
tattoos and bring them to the events and
document them tattooing gears of war
fans
and gears inc is this huge like cultural
thing or it's like
a part of that the gears community is
that you get a gears of war tattoo of
any of the various things and it is like
very curated specific artists like i
know there's one in la there's one in
london
i think there's one in new york um and
that's just a thing that works so well
with the gears of war brand
because it is this like gritty chainsaw
you know that's like a um
that's that feels very similar to how uh
cd projekt red made maul the official
cosplayer of geralt
um like like he unless i
am remembering that wrong but i'm pretty
sure he is basically taking all the
yeah he's like the designated and they
release
they release cosplay guides like they
will release
like they'll release like schematics
basically on how to do
their characters in cosplay for this to
me it strikes me as the same
it's the same concept like people are
showing up as our characters
are only getting lands their characters
were intentionally designed with cosplay
in mind
of course like that's that's the best
thing about borderlands is the world
that they created i
want to see a borderland show are you
kidding me cosplayers look so cool as
well because they always
sell shade that make up it's awesome um
yeah i have to run again
i know i know i know so l.a noire
yeah tell us how or else did you want to
talk about l.a noire
and yeah and the emmy nominations
congrats to the ludwig
gorinson on nomination for mandalorian
he i'm down to
the deal next week i feel like this is
the second week in a row where i'm like
austin you have many interesting things
to say i'm sorry that we always run out
of time no i i only i only bring it
because it was so
validating that uh a few folks on
twitter were like
hey wait what was that little thing at
the end it's gonna be like we start off
in the weird cold open thing and then we
end it with like and by the way here's
what i think about the aliens that we
fou
it progressively gets more and more
intense until i have to leave basically
it's so sad
um but yeah i didn't buzz kill over here
yeah
mom's pulling the station wagon back
into the house
don't keep your hands to yourselves i'm
turning this around right now
i literally am supposed to be live in
five minutes and it happens every week
and i have to be like i'm so sorry
i'm here by the way cheers on publishing
while being live
this past week i thought the headline up
because of that though i was literally
live while publishing and then i was
writing the headline and then when i was
done and i looked at it and i was like i
need to change this headline it also had
a typo originally i was like i don't
know i should never do that again i was
like do both at once it's fun
all i know is that i happen to refresh
youtube in that moment because it showed
up
and then i click and of course there's
already 20 comments and they're all like
you don't like japanese people and i
thought the headline did not say that
how did it get here i was like why did
the faces look odd
because the inner lip sync looks off but
but just the fact that people said that
within 60 seconds of the episode being
live is the thing that made me laugh
because i thought
you couldn't possibly have seen it like
it's literally been on youtube
for less than a minute anyway you have
to go go go
go i did want to say in closing because
i feel like we didn't touch on it enough
i enjoyed the xbox showcase i was happy
that
uh with everything shown there and i
oddly feel virtually exactly
and no one's gonna believe me but the
same about the most recent playstation
conference like i was like
cool with both uh solid variety of games
from both things that i want to play
from both
um i'm interested to see if we get more
conferences throughout august as is the
current rumor so
uh we will see you actually in
august this is the last july episode
we'll see you next month
bye everyone